hey what's up guys my name is the cherno
and welcome to an update video that will
show you guys what I've done with the
website and essentially I guess the new
forums alright so this is my website if
you guys haven't haven't been there you
guys haven't registered yet I encourage
you guys to do that link is in the
description the reason you guys are
going to do that of course is because of
mainly the forms right now okay i'm
working on other stuff as well but we
should be released this month by the way
but most of all I guess the forums are
the big kind of selling point in this
website so um this is my website right
it's the channel I'm Augustus is right
there it'll be a link in the description
in case you guys I want to don't want to
type it out make that [ __ ] your homepage
i know i haven't probably should still
google for me but um let's get on to
this ok so what you going to want to do
is register if you haven't already but
i'm just gonna log in i'm actually gonna
log in as a different account here just
yannick are gonna hit login here and
essentially what you're going to want to
do is once you are logged in and you
will know you're logged in because it
said log out here go to forums ok and
this has changed you can see that we've
upgraded the forms to view the read-only
forum see so this is like the the old
kind of forums right and I've made them
read only to the non posso anymore but
essentially the forums used to look like
this ok this is what they not that's not
it oh [ __ ] I gotta why does it link to
that I've screwed up a link here
wonderful I want to fix that ok so this
is what the old ones look like it /
forum for the old ones so this is this
what this one looks this would it used
to look like right and there's not much
wrong with that I guess except for the
fact that I really don't like what they
look like right this this is like the
built-in forums until because the the
CMS that I'm using for this is Drupal
NLO you guys were wondering but it's
Drupal this is like the advanced forum
module for Drupal and it's it's like
it's decent but i just don't like what
it looks like and there's not much you
can do really again and especially you
can see that there were not 638 posts
and this is probably about 200 that's
wrong fix that up anyway so you can see
that this is kind of really kind of
stale and if you go to something like
this you can see the amount of spam over
here look at this crap and it's really
hard to modern
right that kind of thing with in Drupal
so what I've done is instead of dealing
with this crap and it's not even like
honestly I can't even be bothered
replying to people on this like the
aesthetic just isn't great okay like I
just I don't feel really comfortable I
don't feel like it's like I don't feel
like I'm enjoying myself when I'm on
these forums so I decided to switch them
out into a PHP BB again I'm sure you
guys have heard of PHP BB they pretty
much the most popular can inform
management thing in the world so if you
go to if you go to the forms button here
or / forums right not forum for rooms
you'll go to this page okay if you if
you had a post in the other one I
haven't migrated them because that is
way too much work if you had posts in
the other one in / forum and they
haven't been answered yet you know you
can still view them if you if someone
said something you can still view them I
haven't deleted them yet but if see you
if you ask a question like in this game
programming for example there's a bunch
here I think that have here that have 0
replies if you guys have asked a
question and it hasn't been looked as
Andy solos guy bloody active as hell
that's what that's what I'm talking
about that bro needs a frickin shout out
right there to Andy sellers anyway so
because uh because I'm a few you guys
didn't get answered here or whatever I
encourage you guys just posted in this
okay the categories are the same you can
see someone called glitchy has already
made a post he's the first post guy but
the point is these look much better okay
there are a few uh I guess is like
there's few issues with the interface in
a way like with with the CSS like the
search forum boxes way too big I'm
working on that okay and also there's
these annoying titles everywhere i'm
working on that they are still kind of
in in progress but some so there you go
please continue you and you can see this
looks much better it's in my opinion I
might still play around with what it
looks like but this is going to be way
easier for me to moderate and reply to
as well as um as well as of course for
you guys to just to just chill out in
and get your questions acid okay so i am
bringing back 3d game programming i was
going to do it last month but i'd run
out of time and I was kind of in holiday
mode and just relaxing is there
I'm going to bring it back hopefully in
this month in January but the point is
that it is coming by 30 and programming
is going to be coming back don't worry
you guys don't you worry child okay and
then you've got all these other forms
here as well okay so the idea of these
forms of course is especially the
YouTube video series forums is if you
guys have questions regarding to the
series and wonder whether it be 3d game
programming game programming or network
chat programming there's the three main
series that have got going on on my
channel if you guys are having issues
with that you code is not working
whatever post into this forum and people
will reply ok at least I will I will
definitely reply but there are a lot of
other people here who are who are really
active as like Andy cells for example
India in the previous forums and of
course there'll be as active here if not
more so go ahead and post into these
guys and this game development one is
really cool ok there's a lot of
collaboration going on in the old forms
oh god they look so crap in the old
forms the collaboration one you can see
that there's a lot of stuff going on
here like people have these game ideas
and a lot of people are working together
to make games which which i think is
really really cool showcase is awesome
if you guys have made games you want
other people to play them while check
them out that's a great way that's a
great thing to to do and of course off
topic if you just want to chill out and
talk to people about other stuff like
hey Breaking Bad was awesome everyone
should watch it that's enough topic ok
anyway um I hope you guys enjoyed this
update ok it is a cool little update i
love it oh here's another thing you
might not be logged in on this ok if you
can't post here or whatever for whatever
reason so it says login over here
instead of log out ok then logout of
main thing over here and then log back
in again and what it should do is it
should make you an account in this
automatically when you login I don't
know if it does it automatically for
people who are already logged in you
might have to log out and log back in
again the first time and then it should
make you an account here and you'll be
able to do everything as normal but
anyway that's the update ok I hope you
guys enjoy this I certainly am and
thanks for watching guys as always leave
a like if you guys did enjoy this update
I'm going to be working on the side a
lot more
on this coming month there's actually
some really cool stuff coming some
exclusive content on this site so make
sure that you guys do make an account
and join up to the forums and let's have
some fun alright thanks for watching
guys goodbye